well that's the problem of censorship
and echo chambers of people just
following the same voices the same ideas
the same kind of viewpoints just
regurgitated to them with different kind
of uh points with them but essentially
they're just regurgitating the same
thing doubling down and be becoming more
radicalized uh this is why censorship
needs to be pushed back at all costs and
uh i mean you're here i have a lot of
questions i want to ask especially about
your algorithm but we could save that
later let's do it right now i mean we're
talking about so so we were just talking
about how joe biden can come out and
claim the the upcoming election is going
to be illegitimate but youtube bans and
censors those conversations twitter
censored information on on hunter
biden's laptop which would have changed
the results of the election facebook did
the same thing you andrew are the ceo of
gab and i think are you are you the only
uh social media platform that uses the
first amendment as it's as its rule book
the only one we are the only free speech
platform i think mines does that too do
they yeah first amendment and it's based
on law in connecticut the state where
it's incorporated so interesting yeah
well good for both of you guys excellent
attitude but let's
let's break this down uh gab has been
attacked they've tried to shut you down
they've gone off you've gone after your
infrastructure
you you you have sitting in front of you
a pocket declaration of independence and
constitution you say it's it's it's if
it doesn't you know if it's if it's
within the first amendment people are
allowed to say it
why are they are the these big tech
companies trying to take a gab offline
right so we are the most no platformed
censored d-platformed whatever you want
to call it start-up technology start-up
in history we've been banned from both
app stores because apple and google came
to me and they demanded that we censor
things that they didn't like and i said
no absolutely not because you don't make
the same demands of facebook and twitter
you can find hate speech on twitter you
can find hate speech on facebook and i'm
not going to censor it because you're
not making them censor it okay so i
refused to bend the knee and they banned
us from the app stores they actually
banned our entire developer account in
apple's case we've been banned from
banks tim we've been banned from every
payment processor we've been banned from
hosting services right email services
about 30 plus different services all in
all right with all the infrastructure
that it requires to run a social media
website so what we've done over the past
five and a half years since i started
gab is we've built our own people go say
if you don't like it it's the free
market go build your own that's exactly
what we did we are the only platform
that has done that all these other
platforms that are coming out now
they're saying we're the free speech
platform if you look at where their
servers are hosted they're hosted on
amazon if you look at who they depend on
it's apple and google on the app stores
if you look at their terms of service
they have the exact same terms to
service as facebook as twitter so it's
basically silicon valley but with a new
logo okay and that's not what we're
building what about mines are they on
amazon at the moment they were on amazon
as of six months ago and i talked to
bill and i was like uh we're moving off
amazon
i haven't followed up with them since
that conversation that's the only way
forward is building your own
infrastructure and we've had to build it
all we have our own physical server
hardware racks okay and we have to
physically maintain those and upgrade
those and swap out new hard drives and
and all that type of stuff and that is
just a massive amount of work for what
reason so so they say if you don't like
twitter go make your own and you did and
then all of a sudden different companies
seemingly unrelated sort of knocking out
the support beams from your service
right
i can understand so you mentioned you
know google says hey we want you to
censor certain things said no so they
ban you but what about banks why did
bank ban you well they tried attacking
us from every different angle from after
three weeks after we launched actually
five and a half years ago they started
with the smear campaign right it's
alt-right it's nazis it's all this stuff
right and that didn't work we kept
growing we kept getting bigger so then
they said okay surely if we ban them
from the app stores then they're not
gonna go anywhere right a social network
without an app on the app stores it's
dead in the water and we kept growing
and then we kept growing and growing and
growing and they said okay we're gonna
take we're gonna go after their bank
accounts we're going to go after payment
processors and they when they can't
process payments they're done there's no
way a business can exist on the internet
without being able to accept credit
cards or or paypal or all these major
you know payment infrastructures and
thanks to stuff like bitcoin and uh
checks physical checks that people would
mail into our po box so we had old
technology and new technology and that
is what kept us afloat for an entire
year before we were able to build our
own payment system and come up with our
own solution so
you're uh on the forefront the the the
in terms of protecting actual free
speech which means you've got probably a
lot of detestable conversations and
really awful people i'd imagine yeah
it's words on the screen right a lot of
people that i don't agree with a lot of
people that don't like me a lot of
people that say a lot of nasty things
about me and my family and it's allowed
and that's actually how you know that
it's a free speech platform there's a
there's a parody account of me called
andrew tuba
and i think it's one of the funniest
accounts on gap it's actually one of my
favorite accounts and maybe they don't
know this but i find it hilarious
because you know you see that and and
that is allowed on there you could find
stuff like that on there even about me
the founder the owner right i don't i
don't i i really don't know if i should
bring it up but people have mentioned
that uh
posts critical of of the getter crew
have been removed is that absolutely
false no that's absolutely fine didn't
do any of that stuff no no absolutely
not oh they're removing it or we are no
no no no i've heard
that on getter oh yes yes people have
questions i thought you were saying we
were doing that we're like no
no no is that true though what i saw
people chatting it and i want to be
careful because if it's if i can't prove
it i don't want to bring it up
what i've heard is anybody that's
critical of miles uh their billionaire
their chinese billionaire um who's
behind it we had the conversation about
fuentes the other day with the ceo of
getter
and i i
i don't want to drag a specific platform
into this but considering you know jason
miller was just here and it's very
obvious to everybody i didn't find his
response adequate on what rule was
broken by nick fuentes
look man my position has always been
this oliver darcy of cnn interviewed me
in 2018 when they started banning the
alt-right from twitter and i said it's a
dangerous precedent we we always have
been you know as as and i'm going to say
the the
as liberals in this country because i
grew up in chicago from the city i've
always been left-leaning we're always
about free speech and then all of a
sudden twitter's like we're banning only
this group of people
and i'm like if they're not threatening
violence if they're not targeting people
even even to a certain degree an
argument about harassment i'd be willing
to accept you just don't like their
opinions well i don't like their
opinions either argue them like the aclu
and they defended really awful people in
skokie illinois that famous story now
they're all not doing it they're backing
away they're all going full
authoritarian
so my position has always been
i recognize
nasty people say nasty things
i think we agree on that but when he
says you know jason miller oh well you
know we didn't want to service his group
the problem he he brought up uh
he opened the door forgetter the problem
was he basically said black lives matter
all banned critical race theorists all
banned modern progressives all banned
all of these prominent lifting
personalities what's what's that lady's
name jamila jamil or something is she
that actress woman yeah she was on she's
banned yeah yeah she's been she plays
tundra
stuff
if if if ghetto wants to have that
standard
then the crazy thing about this is
the modern right in this country today
is posting martin luther king jr quotes
they don't want people to be judged on
the color of their skin
but if you come out like like miller did
and say
we're not going to allow anyone who
breaks that rule it's like okay well
that means the republican modern
republican party is going to be on the
platform the democrats won't be right
nicholas j fontes is the canary in the
coal mine with censorship i mean this
kid is 23 years old he has a live stream
from his parents
house and he can't get on a plane
because of his political opinion he
can't access you know he's he's probably
just as banned as we are uh in terms of
platforms now of course you can find him
on gab unlike getter and you know
jason's answer is just totally
unacceptable you look at uh getters
terms of service and they ban hate
speech and they make these arbitrary
decisions like banning nick fuentes and
banning people like john miller even
you know with no reason and no recourse
and no adjudication
and then they claim to be a free speech
platform it's a joke i didn't like it
when
i asked him what you know luke luke
asked him what rule was broken
specifically well the terms and services
right because he has a list and a number
i was like give me you know give me the
list tell me he didn't he didn't have
one he didn't clarify there's difference
between terms of service and community
guidelines which for me there's not at
mines for me i i base my community
guidelines were the terms of service but
i understand how you could have two
different things at least that was his
response that's what i got from that
what worried me the most guidelines were
were violated i don't know it's it
sounded like they were just twitter
but a little bit better right a little
bit better and so there's still the
inherent problem that the reason they
banned nick fuentes is because the media
said bad things about him right look for
all i know what the media claims
about him was true for all i know
however i don't really trust the media
so i'm not going to just blindly be like
oh okay you banned him because cnn wrote
an article i'm going to be like uh
you're going to show me some hard proof
because the media doesn't have any
credibility right now he didn't have it
he couldn't give me a specific example
he couldn't give me there was not even a
philosophical reason it was just you
know fuentes said something about who
are gropers here and so then i asked him
what a gruper wasn't it he didn't seem
to know that either and so my my view is
if you're going to ban someone
stand by it be proud of it and not be
able to explain what went wrong how am i
supposed to trust your platform you know
if he had come out and said we banned
him because we believe that apple and
google would remove us from the stores
if we had him on the platform i would
have respected that right but you know
jason is is a political strategist
that's what he does he's not a
technologist he doesn't know how to run
a social media company and frankly he's
in over his head i think it's obvious
after last night right uh you know what
these people are doing is they're really
trying to subvert the work that i've
been doing for five and a half years and
the work that we've been doing at gab
and it's really it's us versus the
billionaires so you know you have uh
myles gao who is the chinese billionaire
behind getter you have peter thiel who's
behind rumber rumble and you have
rebecca mercer in the mercer family
who's behind uh parlor what about mines
yeah they're aaron yeah that's it yeah
we got you guys are independent
crowdfunding as well started from the
beginning with nothing and then john
came in bill's dad is half owner of the
company and the three of us it's a
family business just like us yep exactly
mine does have a big mine's just taken
investments in the past we got a 10
million about it two years ago um from
the dude that i don't know how is it all
public information i don't know if i
think about names but he basically built
the the games that yahoo bought in like
2000 to create yahoo games right that
guy came in
um we had uh the guy from overstock yeah
he's the he's previously there isn't he
coming with six million about four years
ago but that's i think other than that
it's just we crowdfunded a million bucks
yeah so that's what we did we did
regulation crowdfunding so our users a
nice chunk of our users are actually
stockholders in cab so they have a piece
of the pie and they're our biggest
advocates right um and outside of that
we're funded by you know our gab pro
subscriptions merchandise you know stuff
like this hat um and we now have
advertisement but you know we're not
tracking you creepily like facebook and
stuff did you guys ever have any big
funders coming your way and try to say
hey we're gonna give you this money if
you do this and are you willing or able
to disclose the largest kind of funder
is there one guy who's like a
millionaire that gave you guys a million
dollars is or you know you don't have to
answer it but i'm just curious i think
our average investment was a thousand
dollars for our regulation crowdfunding
offerings we did have a few bigger angel
investors who and by the way all these
people are users on the site um who put
in i think maybe 100 000 or something as
a part of that overall round of
crowdfunding but anybody was able to
invest i think as low as 200 this was
back in 2017 2018. um we have had people
that have come to me and have tried to
tempt me with money absolutely i've had
you know big hedge fund guys and a lot
of names that a lot of people would
recognize if i said them i'm not going
to do that but you know essentially the
deal was you have to start banning
certain things and you have to start
doing things a little bit differently
and we have to pivot on certain things
and i said unacceptable unacceptable
because the thing that
i'm not doing this for money this is my
life's work i am doing this so that when
my children get older
they have the ability to speak freely on
the internet i want to ensure that my
kids have the same and your kids by the
way and your kids have the same freedoms
that we all grew up with in this country
that is why i do what i do period thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you